et c'est reparti toujours à la merise de
trappe sans strap un proche amie line
j'ai cinquième édition colis va nous
réveiller public à base de nos matches
mais vous pensez aux noms onomatopées
c'est sa marque de fabrique
c'est son deuxième mais voilà effet tapé
les gens dans les mains tape dans les
mains qui n'est pas une opa
c'est marrant parce que sa petite
musique
with this might on y jouait ladies night
dans le jeu lapins crétins avec mes
colocs
quand j'habitais
par des métiers non
on a eu de bonnes choses owen wright h
quelle voix touchante et alors qu'est ce
qui se dit
tout ce qui se dit marion à la à la
pause là vous savez moi c'est un footeux
oui à la pause quand il ya des trucs qui
ont été ou courbe a été en général on
essaye de recadrer un peu de se dire
ouais attention là on a mené sur la face
à ce qui c'est pareil ou est-ce que
voilà on reste chacun on se propose pour
les équipes
tout dépend des gens moi je sais que
j'aime bien parler d'autre chose
si moi je suis pas satisfaite de moi je
vais être un petit peu un petit peu
renfermé chaplin
ça dépend s'il ya des gens qui ont
besoin d'en parler on écoute un peu
bidon
chacun sa ses besoins en un projet de
poliment qui fait la différence
autour d'eux d'excellentes de la
brillance à la lumineuse mais la ville
lemoine tout de rouge vêtu chez soi
[Musique]
ils ont pris des formes et les petit
tout petit poney avec de façon à ne pas
se blesser car c'est maintenant que tout
se joue
c'est maintenant la deuxième partie de
sa match d'improvisation t
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais je disais ça gentiment
forcément improvisation mixte tu
rapportes n alors c'est un thème qui va
se plaît vous êtes venu point e point s
nombreux points esprit x et d'écriture
inclusive nombreux joueurs illimité
catégorie libre durée de cette
improvisation quatre symphonies nombreux
jeunes nombreux venu nombreux lots 4
minutes
écoutez on est sans doute vous êtes né
serait pas surprise qu'on voit un
enterrement
je ne serais pas surprise à quoi on peut
bien nombreuses et nombreux un mariage
toutes sortes de cérémonies
anniversaires oui toute sorte de
cérémonie religieuse ou pas un héritage
oui c'est un notaire away noté
j'aimerais bien voir des jeunes allez
allez vous regarder je crois dominique
bien je la la la soirée est prête
j'espère ça va bien se passer
je vais faire en sorte que ça se passe
bien ils vont venir nombreux nombreuses
des hommes des femmes ou contourner tous
bien et du tpn
écoutez je t'en prie quoi qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est-ce qu'il ya des salles et de
parler comme ça je ne veux pas surtout
de chanter de yark un problème tu peux
t'exprimer arrête sa tante jeanne de
tout de suite je suis bienveillant je ne
voulais pas tout alors c'est qu'il s'en
est très important pour moi il n'y a pas
de point très important pour moi parce
que c'est une joie vous faut être bien
la porte est ce que tu veux tu peux te
domine si tu veux te tenir je vais
essayer de faire c'est pas qu'on soit
vous mesdemoiselles mesdames na li ou
pas fiancés peu importe en concubinage
n'y a aucun problème
blanche de toutes couleurs
je sais que je vous ai pas que vous êtes
des femmes mais ça ne nous dérange pas
comment je peux vous servir pouvait ou à
manger et laisse voilà attendait que
justice je prends juste en aparté est ce
que tu peux le faire sa demande
mais non voilà quelques mois mais là un
truc normal marraine malgré leur
orientation sexuelle
nous disons cela seulement vous êtes
très très gentil très gentille de vernon
mais je peux me permettre
monsieur on voit que vous faites
beaucoup d'efforts mais sa masse et sa
met mal à l'aise c'est à dire que
d'accord en général on parle pas de la
vie sexuelle des gens quand on les
rencontre à une soirée le relever la
passionnée de femme soudain pour sentir
obligés de nous dire vous êtes seul
belge auprès de m'excuser général et
mettre un buzz facebook pour m'excuser
vous inquiétez pas je n'ai pas l'appel
si j'étais juste que je ne peux pas que
vous pensiez que je vous ai bien un
problème avec les homosexuels j'ai un
ami homosexuel
[Applaudissements]
je viens de m'excuser sur facebook bien
est ce que tu vas me sers de taguer sur
vos excuses à la porte par bon soir
[Applaudissements]
ça va ma testicules
patrick calbet il ya de windows qui se
sont guère réjouir de loin franchement
elle franchement sont pas attendus
nagoya non pas ma culture mon mariage
génital masculin problème avec notre
façon de faire le créneau
je peux pas t'en patrick c'est quoi ça
moi je vais plus supporter ces tapis
c'est là que tu pourras aller déjeuner
chez ta mère je préfère quand même
est-ce que tu pourras aller sur ton
compte facebook et posté ses excuses
est ce que tu peux faire meilleur
qu'attendu ou là patrick pouvoir écouter
on est pro on essaie de faire d'avenir
pour que cette soirée se passe très bien
alors fameux de la conduite de manière
conviviale s'amuse à jouer
voyez ces conclusions demi défense et à
gagner est ce que ce soir c'était gagné
un mario
merci de votre réaction alors on disait
sur arnaud joyet tout cas l'air tout à
l'excédent joueurs wii alors qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de certains pro vida
sion et
écoutez il y avait de très bonnes idées
ce que propose deux joueurs base est de
décomposer de vocabulaire comme dans le
stand très bien
ce que vient proposer joueurs trop belle
écoutez voilà ya des bonnes choses mais
faut qu'ça matchs 3 et le dénommé bon
c'est à l'impôt c'est tellement magique
quand c'est ma ville de cambrai -
améliorer composer un surcoût de ré que
ce soit
j'ai très bien très bien du mari
désordre social polyvalent rabot
mobilisation inflation mythe ce que
rapporte m tais toi et tu consommes
nombre de joueurs est limité
catégorie à la manière des havres des
films de jacques tati improvisation cinq
minutes et 30 secondes
et oui beaucoup de polémiques autour du
black friday 1
il ya des manifestations et blocages de
magasins ed centrale est tout simple oui
mais oui ton amour nous regarde et nous
on fait des courses et il y entre si ça
c'est du papier parce que le jour j ce
tronc cette émission bien nous sommes le
29 le vendredi 29 novembre m si vous
regardez ça et que nous sommes le 5 ou
le 6 décembre le 24 décembre à acheter
de la viande à ses propres et jacques
tati qui n'a rien à voir avec des
magasins à bardin signé avec ma tête a
maintenant sur toi ni l'un ni l'autre
jacques tati réalisateur leurs
inconvénients est ce que ces grands pas
lutter ces films non oui espaces
[Musique]
millau
[Applaudissements]
promotion au rayon
autre et qu'on les poissons chats vivent
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ici
le petit antoine le petit antoine est
attendu par sa part sa maman
[Musique]
ah bah si on sait que j'achète tellement
facile
oui je n'achète pas 1 5 euro j'ai envie
de vivre eux antoine est poursuivi par
sa maman
au rayon
antoine coûtait trop cher toi tu me
comprends ans n'est ce pas j'ai toujours
aimé comme une promotion qui aime son
produit qui est en promotion
tu veux une tartine de nutella bowie
s'est pas vu de palme en oui les orangs
outans oh oui les rêves en guise en
fourrant bientôt l'huile de palme ouvre
la bouche c'est bien c'est ça la vie au
moins on est sûr la famille on n'est pas
sûrs la famille on ne sait pas aller là
elle est pas là mais pour l'argent on
peut acheter ces messieurs c'est là le
produit et la fermeture du magasin et
une upi n'ont pas de nom qu'est-ce qu'on
devient le tu fais sérieusement je mange
une tortue a tant fait
ma vie le petit antoine va vivre sa vie
[Musique]
passe à la caisse
[Applaudissements]
nous recevrons à l'instant un message de
jacques tati lui-même oui à la donne
aurait de la ducasse qui doit être fait
rage voilà - ah bah embrasser les de ma
part alors qu'est-ce que ça alors mais
vous pensez vous vous avez une histoire
là oui les enfants ont-ils voyager
ont-ils relevé avec ces mamans qui tue
non on va écouter la faute justement
tout aussi de deux marques
la capitaine oui vous utilisez ça alors
que nous on ne touche pas d'argent de
deux de ses produits vous comprenez on
aime les sponsors qui que ce soit c'est
en europe complémentaires monsieur je
sais très bien vous êtes engagé
capitaine
très fortement simplement s'il vous
plaît j'en ai laissé passer quelques
unes mais là trop c'est trop capitaine
ce déballage de mort j'ai envie je sais
je sais mais vous êtes une artiste
complète capitaines n'était né je sais
que vous êtes capable capable de passer
au delà de ça je suis en plus c'est ce
qu'on disait à l'instant il ya un petit
échange qui vient de se faire en vitrine
ou bien encore la vérité chrétienne qui
évidemment a du bagout est-ce que ça va
profiter à cette équipe est ce que nous
allons voir
c'est ce que nous allons voir
[Musique]
effectivement c'est bp qui est variable
cinquième point pour les bleus et 4
points toujours pour les jaunes
ah bah ça s'enchaîne rapidement on n'a
même pas de tort de dire une phrase que
l'armée serait déjà en train d'annoncer
un thème etc vous reparler de ce nom
existe et c'est bouclé mixte pour thème
la destinée chaque t2 shield ou nombre
de joueurs et 8e de cette improvisation
nombre d'annuités catégorie libre de
cette position du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je me fais un devoir de faire
des feuilles de match et on sait
thème là j'ai envie de dire attention
clichés partir d'un cliché avec un thème
pareil à capteur par clémence a fait
défaut mais à la bruce lee à la bouche
vive accord non justifiée de ses propos
oui mais des ballons
j'aime pas c'est celle à venir essayer
ça pas besoin de 70 nous venait tout
droit de hong kong précision de la
jugent généralement c'était vraiment
tirer des belles histoires de temps que
le jeu était approximatif mais avec des
histoires c'est parti et celle de kung
fu c'est chiant je pensais pouvoir
partir seul sans vous prévenir mais nous
voilà pris en flagrant délit
puis c'est moi je ne vous punir et pas
cette fois chouette je fais partie oui
mais doublé fa je serai toujours juste
là je te dis dray
dans sa quête n'est ce pas chambly pas
défaut avait émis son cachet tué je n'ai
pas peur de toi
ces mesures sont les questions
ainsi tu es venu jean dessous pourra
tenir à distance
tu ne m'attendra jamais me savais que
j'aurais dû mettre les mains de ben oui
je vais abandonner petit et je ne
pouvais pas tenir l'école d'arts
martiaux de6 étude toute la souffrance
que j'ai vu ce que donnait la montagne
qui a abandonné à faire une chaîne
encore fait assez de temps parce que sa
tonte avait abandonné en avait abandonné
devant une mairie pas la montagne a
rejeté croyez s'était énervé mais en
fait c'était un caillou
[Musique]
quand même faire la différence entre un
caillou
[Applaudissements]
c'était mon coup matin et tu n'as rien
senti de ce qui provient des
élémentaires
nous avons les mêmes techniques c'était
cool dans nos champs je suis navré
d'avoir abandonné quel âge as-tu trois
ans quatre ans
[Applaudissements]
pas bien julie servions extraordinaires
les uns baigneurs un duo improvisé qui
tourne en france
les autres n'ont pas les horizons à tous
deux jouent bien sûr entendre dans les
autres avaient construit un prototype
mais
c'est un champion extraordinaire et
c'est un duo d'amy aussi ça passe après
marc nom de ce vaccin calamity
c'est
car encore un mini break comme tout à
l'heure
on va voir si les jaunes vont recoller
au score remportait un adjectif nombre
de joueurs il émettait catégorie libre
par en catégorie à la manière des hommes
de tennessee williams tirer de cette
improvisation sept minutes
[Applaudissements]
alors on en retrouve un petit peu dosé
s'avouera pas certaines chansons de joe
dassin selmani si joe dassin veille
québec à mes amis on a tous quelque
chose que je sais c'est que j'allais
vous dire on a tous quelque chose en
nous de tennessee williams à 8 l et si
très belle chanson de johnny hallyday
mais absolument
je crois que nous sommes singer par des
joueurs que je vois y aura des cours
actuel est bon je dis caliber et antoine
un rabot allez c'est parti
ça
vous en avez acheté d'autres des
j'en ai 11
et si beaucoup vous êtes complet
non pas de limites
c'est pour un avoir tranche jean marais
30 je m'en fous
mamie oui mais là
j'aimerais bien me rajouter 1 12
au lieu du special event mardi qu'ils
feraient quoi qu'il serait beaucoup de
choses pour la maison nokia n'a rien
baby
quoi
mais qui s'occupent de moi ce serait
mort ou d'esclaves personnel ça vous
n'êtes pas satisfaites
pour élever à longueur de journée plus
rien ne fonctionne chez vous
vous êtes un peu agi pour moi s'il vous
plaît chez moi mais comme mon père
débarqué à boston c'était encore un cas
la gamme
je ne suis plus un cas la dame rod fanni
kinderen family portrait de moi c'est
mon anniversaire demain
regardez il a développé tous les sens
ils pourraient travailler dans les shows
et la billette autres et où on me fait
souffrir ma mort avait dit quelque chose
d'intelligent
je sais écrire ici à madeco qui sait
aller dit on je suis josette lapèze ou
mes anciens mes anciens maîtres étaient
des professeurs d'école
c'est même jouer du piano et faire la
cuisine
[Musique]
je mens le planeur qui viennent ce mois
ou plus
[Musique]
ça me rappelle maman tout tout tout
j'appelle ma mère lui pas tellement que
je lui met une robe de votre mère aimée
ou qui a tout ce que vous voudrez si on
t'avait pas les champs tenez prenez une
autre sphère mais loeb
si vous aussi vous le voulez si vous
pouvez vous vous demandez ce poulet déjà
puisque je viens ce père se défouler je
sais mais on s'est fait prendre dans ses
bras
laisse moi faire car le garde chasse us
passe dessus c'est moi qui avais tu sais
que l'esclavagé a été aboli depuis 1848
et toi tu continues dans mon petit con
tour avoir des esclaves se sont pas sont
des travailleurs je vois la santé de la
crapule que tuer j'allais perdre
[Applaudissements]
je les paie je ne crois tu pas il joue
du piano il va me prendre dans ses bras
de lesparre faire joseph deiss par saint
joseph tu vas la robe de la maire de
bobigny on est à peyriac je l'appelais
boulet non tu peux toujours fait
maintenant oui merci à châtel vous avez
été tellement bonne avec moi merci
beaucoup total sur les autres actifs
j'apporte tous mon enfant une seule je
vous aimais depuis le premier jour et je
porte tout en revers alors comment on
pourrait partir je me levais cet enfant
au oui je vous emmènerai et s'il nous on
en passe saturé jeu tu en penses a pris
la leçon piano est terminée et encore
une fois encore une qu'on aura loupé oui
elle l'a sauvé encore un et nous
l'adorons n'est conservée aventure
ma mère est partie une deuxième fois
dans ma vie
vous allez c'est parti vous pouvez
partir de femmes et nous pourrons partie
de l'argent vous tenez une merde jal du
numéro c'est un faux s'il ya un piège
comment et où le mans c'est ce qu'est
venu tirer dans le dos rond central
courir dans le champ vous n'êtes plus
méconnus ou allez vous aussi regagner
votre liberté moi je m'en charge
continue continue
nous avons même eu la bonté m'abandonne
megastore fait mon travail pour vivre
voilà ce qu'ont fait mes débuts
la survie le futur étaient présents le
président est passée la question donnent
pas ces signes a des regrets de nos
morts dans ce chan je le sais plus
facteurs la gueule je te la forme ont
peur vous avez été trop longtemps après
la gamme vous nous avez épuisé
vous nous avez torture et vous ne savez
pas ce que vous méritez c'est entendre
nos voix est rageant mais restera
toujours à contre-courant notre champion
maintenant le canada je reviens là j'ai
accouché le début la cre
si je donne alors la joueuse de walker
vient dire mulâtre en québécois c'est
qu'un métis en français
enfin fait d'être enfin en français
parce qu'un décret parce que les plus
québécoise
mais oui
[Musique]
la cip initialement ça veut aussi dire
un métis c'est mal c'est connoté
péjorativement par mourad esclavage et
ont vu ce que c'était susa des soies des
viols d'esclaves soit plus tard on
appelait aussi les mulâtres puisque
avait du mal il y avait quand même des
rencontres mix qui se faisait or
les catastrophes et tous les viols qu'il
y avait quand même des rencontres et on
a effectivement dans les états unis du
19e siècle
des noirs qui a impacté les mulâtres
aussi la jungle des animaux la jungle
des animaux de ville j'ai entendu des
amis modeuses de vide mais c'est déjà
pas mal parce que j'ai rien entendu des
animaux d'eysines l'histoire peut-être
pas mesdames ciel qu'on a vu également
terminé cette improvisation théâtre elle
a commencé à l'improvisation en 2008
oui avec l'atelier adultes donc
débutants et puis à la queue du chemin
entre temps elle a beaucoup joué à la
beaucoup joué jusqu'à arriver là mais je
vous en dirai un petit peu plus d'une
heure
où
oh
allez
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
m
tha
par jour
[Rires]
oui
[Applaudissements]
m
tél
[Applaudissements]
comme quoi à la linguère mois n'a pas
besoin de parler
et donc voilà tout est dans le dans le
jeu dans le visage le corporel était
super super papa improvisation d'honteux
fabien strobel et julie galibert et
pourtant darby tu n'as pas été
satisfaits qu'est-ce qui vous mon
respect du thème me semble-t-il comme
abba a écouté les habilités la chaîne le
désagrément de la femme et des amis
c'est vrai quand même pas beaucoup de
lille beauvais
mais bon on imaginer aussi votez pour
qui vous voulez mais ce sont les jaunes
même si ce point honnêtement on va lui
être partagée par à des deux joueurs et
de joueuses bah oui mon version gt
c'est une belle histoire c'est une belle
histoire qui termine sur une demande de
mariage est oui
c'est peut-être le thème de la soirée à
venir puisque déjà que mélanie lemoine
nous a paradé introduction avec antoine
arabo que mariage avec caro jean marc de
mariée à certaines jeunes cmj avec je ne
sais quoi
et maintenant c'est un chimpanzé qui
demande en mariage un oiseau à gradins
d'un donc un an
improvisation mixte coeur pour thème à
la frontière d'un monde à la frontière
d'un an de nombre de joueurs illimité
catégorie libre
durée 2 fait un promu nation
à la frontière d'un monde que me
proposait vous chère marion billy boy et
emmener ce que je disais sur amen déjà
puisque elle revient d'un tournoi au
québec et au québec avec l'équipe des
alchimistes d'un preneur de plaisir ils
ont remporté ce tournoi prestige au
québec qui s'appelle le ton à paradoxe
il y avait quand même vingt équipes et
sur les 20 équipes sur les vins etc et
pardon qui ont participé qui a obtenu le
prix de la joueuse d'excellence
d'intégrer pourquoi je me suis corrigé
alors oui je pense que c'est ça et bien
qui à quoi
sur les 20 équipes remportée à mesdames
end
le prix de la joueuse d'excellentes
sommaire juste de tourner au drame ou un
excellent
[Musique]
je crois que le bret j'y trouve à gagner
dans mon cartable
j'aimais ma couleur préférée mes
chaussettes aubenas écoute vos chaises
oui je ne partira pas avec moi
aujourd'hui je sais pas peur avec jackie
chan 6e à washington oui mais tu vas
devoir faire la route tout seul toutes
ces années où j'étais accompagné ou thé
préparé ton goûter ouais je vais rien
arranger ça la vie finito le le dandy
casper je vais vous dire votre avis les
savistes tu n'as pas envie ajouté une
médaille en fait rigoler alors avant que
tu pars tu regardes s'éteint c'est là
que j'ai été poussé avant tu n'es ce pas
dans l'ancien monde sur ces cibles
si jamais vous l'aimez pas vos enfants
cette affaire
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas la pensée leurs jours ok
j'ai mon métier de comédien maman tu
m'avais dit petit peu moins de 10 heures
[Musique]
excusez moi je suis monsieur le maire
tout le monde attend votre corps
paramédical ou dalida
oui à la suite à votre fruit et des
policiers pris en gardant les mains des
bras
[Musique]
ce père est extraordinaire d'avoir
entendu l'entrée quand même de monsieur
le maire à la frontière d'un mandat lors
tous écoutent marion j'attends ma
attendant attendent le vote d'abord du
public
moi je serais plus partisan du x files
et jaune du coup ce sont des jaunes
j'ai dû rêver vous que c'est incroyable
car l'équipe des jaunes égalise
et c'était bien servir bravo bravo à ses
joueurs
merci pour votre invitation merci d'être
venu mais ce n'est pas terminé encore
marion vous allez rester avec moi
nous allons avoir
la traditionnelle mise à jour
remise des étoiles
les dames maria qui joue les étoiles
tiens nous allons choisir nos étoiles
ça c'est un bel exercice alors qui est
ce que vous mettriez vous avez trois cas
trois joueuses ou joueurs en troisième
étoile deuxième étoile est et première
étoile qui vous laisse seul vert bonjour
monsieur nouvelle mettrait alors vous et
vous voyez et galibert trop belle je ne
sais pas dans quel ordre alors joyet
galibert et
[Musique]
il y avait ce soir excusez moi parce que
excusez moi messieurs dames les joueurs
les jeux ceux ci ne voient pas lors du
coup d'envoi
il y avait parmi nous ce soir une
personnalité d'honneur chargé de
remettre les étoiles il s'agit du
président de déclic théâtre il est
président de déclic théâtre depuis
quasiment toujours autant vous dire
qu'il a vu plus de matchs d'impro que
nous tous réunis c'est monsieur
dominique charrier je ne sais pas du
tout irait donc charrier président
emblématique de déclic théâtre et plus
de nombreuses années et vous savez que
d'abord la connaissez charlie mais eux
la tradition des étoiles aussi est en
train de disparaître avec le décorum
initial toi moi j'ai toujours eu
personnellement des réserves avec les
étoiles puisque je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi on métiers des étoiles alors
que dans le même temps on disait que
c'était des robots et autres êtres
l'ensemble ne fallait pas distinguer un
jour une chose pareille il y en a qui
fait qu'ils aient effectivement
reviennent me sarr est alors on va voir
si votre diagnostic si votre pronostique
une joueuse de l'équipe
les jaunes qui porte le numéro 29
[Musique]
étoile de ce match prouve que monsieur
n'a pas réussi à les départager
ils nous ont offert une improvisation
absolument adorable bien entendu vous
les avez reconnus car ce sont les plus
mignons julie
c'est plaisir de jouer ensemble est
essentielle en a pour l'instant votre
pronostique le bon chère marion mai mais
qui va-t-il choisir en première étoile à
leur très cher ami dominique serieys
est-ce que ça va être arnaud joyet
manisha va être peut-être les bio
mézières pour peut être génial walker
suspense il a longtemps fait une faute
de liaison impardonnable
mais visiblement monsieur le président
le pardonne il porte un maillot bleu qui
porte le numéro 47 c'est bien ce que je
pensais à volume au bureau 47 figure
mézières super
[Musique]
oui moment des étoiles c'est toujours
une belle récompense et en même temps
quand on en a pas en tant que joueur on
a beau dire on est content pour les
copains c'était un petit peu un petit
pas ce bon ok on l'a on est content
toute la compagnie déclic théâtre je
tiens à remercier les équipes de la
merise particulièrement l'équipe
technique sans qu'ils aient bien
évidemment vous ne pourriez venu nous
voir ni nous entendre et quel dommage ce
serait merci à eux
franck mathieu fred weill et bien tout
va et gabriel maintenant la rue il ne me
reste qu'à vous remercier immensément
quel plaisir de vous retrouver année
après année vous êtes la famille je vais
me la prendre
les spectacles
[Musique]
mais effectivement merci mario de
m'avoir accompagné télé pour se quitter
ben justement bâtir un petit mot sur ce
spectacle mardi 25 février a maintenant
la caméra elle est là 25 février donc à
20h30
ici même à la merise le spectacle écran
noir qui parle justement du tout cette
dérive des écrans qui nous entourent et
qui peuvent avoir des conséquences
néfastes sur trèbes impunément l'inspiré
de black mirror
je n'en sais rien du coup ça veut dire
ça un petit peu à l'avenir hors écran
noir
oui c'est inspiré de l'acteur je crois
que c'est écrit d'ailleurs dont le petit
pitch qui est présenté rien ne vous
échappe cher mario mais ça fait tout
laurent matter c'est vraiment son
univers et ça va être extraordinaire
remplie
m
merci à tous et à tous de nous avoir
suivis d'avoir publie ce trappe
impro family cinquième édition ont versé
marion merci à toi c'est amélie mais je
vais te tutoyer matin serait maintenant
vous tutoyez on fait ça on se connaît
pas de tout à l'heure en fait lorsque
des petits très longtemps la même veine
un pot ensemble mais c'est dire tout et
merci mario en tout cas merci à pied
merci à toute l'équipe de déclic tu es
assis dcri qui vous a été à préparer et
cette émission et puis cette belle
soirée
géraldine elodie je vais en oublier
certainement l'aurait dit hakim bien sûr
sophie clair et je crois que c'est du
tout le monde que julian voilà et
moi-même également marion versée à
toutes et à tous et à bientôt sur tv 78
bonne soirée
à
[Musique]
coc